thank you Yasser we are here with mihai
padroyo CEO of commercial real estate at
one United Property is one of our uh
very important sponsors here at Superbad
chess classic first of all mihai welcome
to the show tell us a bit about this
partnership
so um one of the founders of one United
properties which is the leading
sustainable mixed use developer
project in Romania
is very keen on chess he's a very big
fan of Chess and
this is how being a long time friend of
Mr dragic
we joined this initiative and we became
one of the the supporters
of also the Romanian Chess Federation
and this competition how would you say
one United's strategy connects with
chess in what ways
well as a listed company we take all ESG
components extremely seriously
as I said we are the leading green
developer in Romania
but going forward we believe that
the key to progress the key to
development
in any society especially an emerging
one like Romania is education and
therefore as much as we can and we are
able to we invest and we support
initiatives that are related to
education
We Believe chess is um
is is
more than um
let's say a recreational activity we
believe that it it structures and it
shapes a young player's mind Vision it
provides balance and this is a great
alternative to to traditional education
and we believe that chess can really
enhance
anyone's uh
life through
development of thought process logic and
and so on so this is why we believe that
we we should support this and we will
always try to to promote chess as as a
movement especially
across
young Generations speaking of education
and the Young Generation how important
it is for the up and coming generation
to see the best chess players here in
Bucharest I think it's amazing even for
me as uh you know let's say a
amateur non-member of this
professional movement let's say to be
able to to see the world champion
playing live and uh to see this
diversity of really
bright Minds is a unique opportunity and
it's a it's an experience that we we
didn't have access to before so I think
everyone is very fortunate and very
thankful
for being able to to take part into into
such an event and also to have it here
in in Romania now I'm going to put you
on the spot who is your favorite player
in this event well of course I have to
support
our Romanian player which is Bogdan so I
hope he does really well and I hope he
wins points for Romania
but again I think all players are are
extremely talented and uh
it's an honor to to have them here mihai
thank you for coming on the show and
thank you for your continued support
thank you guys back to you